Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Four, Episode Four: the United Nations, and Denmark's global cooperation.
Denmark's international relations do not stop at Europe.
Denmark is also a member of many organisations that deal with larger regional or global questions.
One of the most important is the UN.
Denmark also has a large cooperation on development with a number of developing countries in, among other places, Africa, Latin America and Asia.
The UN, the United Nations, Forenede Nationer, FN in Danish, is a worldwide organisation which consists of independent states.
The UN was founded in 1945, shortly after the end of the Second World War.
From the start, the UN had the support of 51 states.
Today the number of members is 193.
Denmark has been a member of the UN since its foundation in 1945.
The UN's most important tasks lie within peace and security, human rights, development activities and humanitarian efforts.
Questions such as conflicts, economy, poverty, hunger, diseases and the environment are therefore central to the UN's work.
In addition, the UN works with children's conditions, women's rights, culture and education.
The UN's headquarters is in New York, but some of its sub-organisations have their headquarters elsewhere in the world, among others in Geneva, Nairobi and Vienna.
The highest leader in the UN is the UN Secretary-General.
The UN holds an annual General Assembly, which takes place at the UN's headquarters in New York.
The General Assembly has many purposes, including discussing current matters in the UN's member countries, adopting the UN's budget, and discussing reports from the UN Security Council.
The main task of the UN Security Council is to deal with conflicts that may threaten international peace and security.
The Security Council has five permanent members.
They are Russia, China, the United Kingdom, the USA and France, which were the five most important countries that helped win the Second World War.
One idea behind this composition was also that wars and conflicts could be avoided by dialogue and cooperation between the then five most significant powers.
The Security Council has ten other member countries.
They are selected by the General Assembly for two years at a time.
Denmark is a member of the Security Council in the period 2025 to 26, and has previously been a member in the periods 1967 to 68, 1985 to 86 and 2005 to 06.
The five permanent members have a veto.
That means that if just one of these countries votes against a decision, it cannot be carried out.
As the countries often have different and conflicting interests, it is often difficult to adopt significant decisions.
Since 1946, the veto has been used 329 times, most often by the Soviet Union and Russia, and the USA.
For example, Russia has in recent years used its veto to block the Security Council from condemning Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
And the USA has, because of its close relationship with Israel, among other things used its veto to prevent the UN from condemning new Israeli settlements in the Palestinian areas.
Another criticism of the UN system is that the global balance of power has changed since 1945, because some of the Security Council's permanent members have lost power and significance in the meantime.
The USA is still regarded as the world's strongest power and China as the second strongest.
But many would say that the Security Council's three European members, Russia, France and the United Kingdom, are no longer global great powers.
In addition, for example neither India, with the world's largest population, nor any countries from Africa or South America, are represented among the permanent members.
Now to Copenhagen.
In Copenhagen lies the so-called UN City, FN-byen, where more than 1,500 people of more than 100 different nationalities work.
The UN City houses 11 UN organisations, including the World Health Organization, WHO, the UN High Commissioner for Refugees, UNHCR, and the UN's organisation to help children, UNICEF.
UNICEF's world warehouse in Copenhagen contains, among other things, medical supplies, school equipment, products to turn dirty water into drinking water and much more, which is sent out to millions of children all over the world.
And the goals.
The UN's 17 Sustainable Development Goals, verdensmål.
The UN's member countries adopted, at a summit in New York in September 2015, the new goals for sustainable development, which form the framework for the global development effort up to the year 2030.
The 17 goals apply to all the world's countries, and thereby also Denmark.
The 17 goals are very ambitious and cover a wide range.
Besides fighting poverty and social development, the goals also focus on economic and environmental development, equality, climate, and include goals for peace and security.
With the goals, the UN's member countries have thus, among other things, committed themselves to abolishing extreme poverty, securing education for all, better health, decent jobs and sustainable growth in all countries.
The 17 goals are: Goal 1, no poverty.
Goal 2, zero hunger.
Goal 3, good health and well-being.
Goal 4, quality education.
Goal 5, gender equality.
Goal 6, clean water and sanitation.
Goal 7, sustainable energy.
Goal 8, decent jobs and economic growth.
Goal 9, industry, innovation and infrastructure.
Goal 10, reduced inequality.
Goal 11, sustainable cities and local communities.
Goal 12, responsible consumption and production.
Goal 13, climate action.
Goal 14, life below water.
Goal 15, life on land.
Goal 16, peace, justice and strong institutions.
And Goal 17, partnerships for action.
The exams also ask about one more UN agreement: in 2015 the UN adopted the Paris Agreement, the climate agreement in which Denmark and many other countries have committed to reducing greenhouse gas emissions.
That fact is not in the textbook chapter itself.
Here is your recap for Episode Four.
The UN was founded in 1945, with 51 states; today it has 193 members.
Denmark has been a member since 1945.
The headquarters is in New York.
The Security Council has five permanent members, Russia, China, the United Kingdom, the USA and France, with a veto, used 329 times since 1946.
It also has ten other members, elected for two years; Denmark is a member in 2025 to 26, and was earlier in 1967 to 68, 1985 to 86 and 2005 to 06.
The UN City in Copenhagen has more than 1,500 employees, over 100 nationalities and 11 UN organisations, including WHO, UNHCR and UNICEF.
The 17 Sustainable Development Goals were adopted in September 2015 and run until 2030.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which international organisation did Denmark become a member of in 1945?
Option A: The EU.
Option B: The WTO.
Option C: The UN.
[DA] Hvilken international organisation blev Danmark medlem af i 1945?  A: EU  |  B: WTO  |  C: FN
The answer is C: The UN.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in November 2024.
[DA] ✔ C: FN
Question 2.
Which international organisation has adopted 17 so-called Sustainable Development Goals on, for example, equality, climate and poverty?
Option A: The UN.
Option B: The EU.
Option C: The WTO.
[DA] Hvilken international organisation har vedtaget 17 såkaldte verdensmål om for eksempel ligestilling, klima og fattigdom?  A: FN  |  B: EU  |  C: WTO
The answer is A: The UN.
It appeared in the November 2022 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: FN
Question 3.
What are Denmark and a number of other countries especially committed to under the Paris Agreement from 2015?
Option A: To reduce the emission of greenhouse gases into the atmosphere.
Option B: To spend more money on defence.
Option C: To cooperate on preventing cross-border crime.
[DA] Hvad er Danmark og en række andre lande især forpligtet til ifølge Paris-aftalen fra 2015?  A: At reducere udslippet af drivhusgasser i atmosfæren  |  B: At bruge flere penge på forsvaret  |  C: At samarbejde om forebyggelse af grænseoverskridende kriminalitet
The answer is A: To reduce the emission of greenhouse gases into the atmosphere.
It appeared in the June 2022, May 2024 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: At reducere udslippet af drivhusgasser i atmosfæren
That's the end of this part.
Well done.